ننتقل للمشاهدين الى اسطنبول وهذا المؤتمر
الصحفي للرئيسين التركي والاوكراني بكم
مره اخرى
في شهر اغسطس الماضي التقينا في مدينه
ليفيف
مع الرئيس
وبعد ذلك كان هناك العديد من الاتصالات
الهاتفيه بيننا
مع صديقي
كان هذا اللقاء قبل سته اشهر في الفيف
وتعلمون اننا قمنا بالكثير من الاتصالات
الهاتفيه
[موسيقى]
وبغض النظر عن كل الاحداث الصداقه التركيه
والاوكرانيه اصبحت اقوى من السابق والشعب
الاوكراني هو في اليوم الخمسمائه من هذه
الحرب الذي سوف ياتي قريبا
ومنذ بدايه
التهديدات والتصادم قمنا بكل الجهود
اللازمه حتى نتجنب الحرب
ومنذ
بدايه
وصول الضغوط الى المراحل الساخنه اعلنا
انه يجب وقف هذه الحرب الغير عادله التي
لا تتناسب مع القوانين الدوليه ومنذ
اقتطاع القرم وضمها كنا نتحدث على جميع
المنصات اننا ندعم سلامه اراضي اوكرانيا
وسيادتها على اراضيها وكل اراضيها
ونحن بشكل عملي اظهرنا دعمنا لاوكرانيا
وقدمنا الكثير من الدعم في المجال السياسي
والاقتصادي والتكنولوجي
وفي
وكذلك الامر
كنا الدوله الاكبر التي قامت بجهود لانهاء
الحرب على اساس القوانين الدوليه
وفي العام الماضي استقبلنا
مفاوضات مهمه جدا بين وفدين من كلا
الدولتين
وايضا في العام الماضي
قمنا
بتنظيم مبادره اتفاق الحبوب
ووقعنا هذه الاتفاقات بفضل الجهود
المشتركه
[موسيقى]
وسوف تنتهي هذه الاتفاقيه قريبا
وهذه الاتفاق التي هذا الاتفاق الذي يؤمن
حوالي 30 مليون شخص بالغذاء الغذاء المهم
لكل العالم ونحن نتمنى الاستمرار بهذه
المبادره اي اتفاق الحبوب واعتقد ان كلا
الطرفين مهتمين بهذا وسوف
يتناسب مع هذا ان اوكرانيا تستحق
ان اوكرانيا تستحق ان تكون عضو في النيتو
[موسيقى]
واريد
في حضوركم هنا وامامكم
ان اقول من جديد وان اعلن شيء مهم ان
السلام العادل هو شيء لن يخسر فيه احد
وسوف نقدم اي دعم ضروري حتى تقف اوكرانيا
على اقدامها وشركاتنا وقياداتنا سوف تدعم
الاسواق الاوكرانيه وسوف تدعم الاصدقاء
الاوكران في اعاده اعماري بلديهم
واحد الاسباب المهمه التي تجعلنا بثقه
نتحدث عن
مستقبل اوكرانيا هو ان التتار في اوكرانيا
يحاربون لاجل استرداد
وطنهم واريد ان اشكر من جديد السيد
زيلينسكي على
عمله على ضمان امن اخواني اخواتي اخواننا
وتحسين اوضاعهم الاقتصاديه واريد هذه
الفرصه لكي اعبر من جديد عن
تعاطفى اتجاه جميع الاوكرانيين الذين
نقضوا نحبهم وسوف نعمل بكل ما هو ممكن حتى
نوقف هذه الحرب ونحن ندعم اوكرانيا بشكل
تام
ونعتقد ان المفاوضات سوف تاتي بالخير الى
دولنا والى دول العالم شكرا للجميع وقبل
كل شيء شكرا لصديقي
ولجميع اعضاء الوفد الاوكراني
[موسيقى]
واريد من جديد
اريد ان اخبركم عن خبر مهم هو انني قدمت
قرار
برفع
التقاعدات للمتقاعدين واعتقد اننا سوف
نقدم كل شيء ضروري شكرا لكم شكرا لك سيدي
الرئيس اردوغان
شكرا
لكم ايها السيدات والساده الحضور ايها
الصحفيين وايها الوفود
وشعب تركيا
المبجل انا سعيد بزياره
لتركيا واريد ان ابارك لك سيدي الرئيس
سانتظر
واريد ان ابارك لك بشكل شخصي
بانتخابك مجددا وان اشكرك واشكر فريقك وكل
مواطن تركي يحاول ان يصل للسلام لشعبنا
واريد ان اشكرك اشكرك على
ضيافتكم وعلى دعمكم للمواطنين الاوكرانيين
الذين وجدوا ملجا في اوكرانيا في تركيا
عفوا في ظروف الحرب والعدوان الروسي ضد
اوكرانيا ان مواطنين يشعر بدفء قلوب
المواطنين التركيين ودعمهم الذين يدعمون
في هذه الظروف الصعبه
اليوم التركيه تظهر دورها القيادي ودورك
سيدي الرئيس في استرداد السلم واسترداد
النظام العالمي والتوازن في العالم نحن مع
السيد الرئيس تحدثنا بتفصيل عن الاوضاع
فيما في منطقه البحر الاسود
ولدينا وجهات نظر متساويه انه لا احد لديه
الحق ان يفرض على دولنا اي شيء في حوض
البحر الاسود
وان لا يفرض علينا ما لا امور لا تصب في
مصالحنا
ويجب ان يكون هناك امن وتعاون في هذا
القطاع وليس حرب
ولا نريد اي نزاعات مجمده قد تشعل النار
من جديد وان تهاجم حياه المواطنين انا
شاكر لتركيا على دعمها الذي لا يتغير
ودعمها
سياده اوكرانيا على جميع اراضيها
وتحدثنا ايضا عن القرم التي تسيطر عليها
روسيا بشكل غير شرعي وفي كل الحالات سوف
نعيد
سيطرتنا القانونيه على القرم وسوف نسترد
الامن لشبه جزيره القرم ولجميع السكان
فيها بما فيهما الشعب التتري الذي الان
للاسف يتعرض لاضطهاد جديد وضغط من قبل
روسيا انا شاكر
لدعم اتفاق البحر الاسود
ومبادره الحبوب الاوكرانيه للاسف روسيا
حتى الان تقوم باعاقه حركه السفن
وتضيق على الممرات خلال البحر الاسود
وروسيا تعتقد ان كل شيء في البحر الاسود
هو لها
ان شعوبنا يحتاج الى المزيد من
الجهود حتى نقوم بتقييد العدوان
الروسي وحتى نعيد الاستقرار لحوض البحر
الاسود ان امن اوكرانيا
والاتفاق الجاري يعتمد عليه الامن الغذائي
في افريقيا ومختلف الدول ويجب ان نساعد
العالم ان يقف ضد
الجوع وضد الازمات
وان نسترد الامن الغذائي ومن المهم ان
نتذكر ان الامن الغذائي سوف يكون له مردود
اقتصادي جيد للشعوب واليوم تحدثنا عن
مختلف المشاريع المتبادله بيننا وممكن ان
نتعامل معا ونحقق جميع المشاريع التي سوف
تقوي دولنا وسوف ترفع مستوى الامن وهذا
يخص التعاون في مجال الصناعه العسك وتطوير
التكنولوجيا وتطوير المسيرات والتعاون في
مختلف المجالات ولدينا اتفاقات ولقد دعوت
تركيا للانضمام للاعمال الواسعه في اعاده
اعمار
اوكرانيا وهذه مشاريع اقتصاديه مهمه ولدها
ولدها تركيا ما يمكن ان تستثمره في
اوكرانيا وانا شاكر لدعمكم لصيغه السلام
التي عرضتها في العام الماضي وسوف نعمل
على تحقيق هذه الصيغه ونحن نحضر لقمه
السلام
وقمه النيتو
وتحدثنا اليوم عن المسائل
الاساسيه للتعاون فيما بيننا في اطار
الناتو وسوف
ولقد تحدثنا عن قمه
وعن ان اوكرانيا تستحق ان تصبح عضوا في
النيتو وشيء اخر تركيا وانت سيدي اردوغان
الكثير ما قمتم به حتى تدعموا تحرير
مواطيء مواطنين الاوكران من الاسرى الروسي
واريد ان اشكركم على هذا والاو
الاوكرانيين سوف يقدر هذا الى الابد
واعتقد اننا نستطيع ان نقوم بالمزيد
للدفاع عن الارواح والدفاع عن الاستقرار
شكرا لكم على هذه الدعوه وعلى هذه
المفاوضات على دعمكم شكرا لكم المجد
لاوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
شكرا لكم شكرا للجميع
الاندفاع
سوف نستقبل سؤالين
احد الاسئله سوف يكون من الضيوف واحد
الاسئله سوف يكون من طرف التركي
من سوف يبدا من الضيوف فليبدا وارجو رفع
الايدي
سؤالي لكلا الرئيسين
تركيا لديها الكثير من الحالات الناجحه في
تحرير الاسرى الاوكرانيين وبما فيهم
التتريين وايضا
المدافعين عن ماريوبل في الوقت الحالي
القرب محتله من روسيا وهناك الكثير من
المساجين
الذين هناك حوالي 170 تتري معتقل
حوالي حوالي 130 هم من التتار القرميين
منهم رئيس
الاداره القرميه ناريمان وايضا هناك اعلان
سابق عن ان
شبكه الممرات الامنه للسفن ممكن ان تستخدم
لاستبدال الاسره ايضا هل هناك اعمال على
هذا المجال وهل من الممكن ان ننتظر
اخبار جيده في الوقت القريب وايضا هل ممكن
ان ننظم
استرداد عن طريق
اوكرانيا عن طريق تركيا هل من الممكن ان
نسترد الاطفال الاوكراني الاوكرانيين
الذين تم نقلهم من اوكرانيا بطريقه غير
شرعيه شكرا لك على هذه الاسئله
نحن
كما تفضل السيد الرئيس التقيت به في المره
الاخيره في الفيف اثناء
اثناء الحرب
وكنت شاكر له على انه زار اوكرانيا في هذه
الاوقات الصعبه ودعمني شخصيا ودعم
اوكرانيا وانا شاكر اننا اليوم هنا وبعد
اعاده انتخاب الرئيس اعتقد انني سوف ادعو
الرئيس واتحدثنا اليوم وكان الموضوع الاول
هو موضوع الاسرى
المختلف الاسرى منهم التتريين
الاسرى السياسيين والمعتقلين
والاطفال ايضا وهذا اول موضوع اتحدث عنه
دائما مع السيد اردوغان في اي وقت حتى في
الهاتف حتى اثناء القصف
حتى اثناء الانتخابات واثناء المرحله
الانتخابيه كنا نتحدث عن هذه المواضيع
بشكل مستمر لان هذا شيء مهم لي وللسيد
الرئيس ان الجانب الاغاثي هو اولويه دائما
نحن نعمل على استرداد
الاسرى والمعتقلين السياسيين والقرميين
وكل القائمات موجوده لدى جميع شركائنا
وهذا ما نعمل عليه بجد وانا اعتقد انه من
الخطا قبل اي نتائج ان اعلق هذه على هذه
الاعمال بتفصيل
ان الناريمان جلال هو شخص احترمه واعرفه
شخصيا
ولقد جاء الى القمه القرميه الاولى في
المنتدى القرمي وقمنا بفتح مكتب هذا
المنتدى وعملنا معا على الخطوات التي كان
من المفروض ان تؤدي الى تحرير المعتقلين
وانا اعتقد ان جميع المعتقلين السياسيين
الاسرى سوف يعود الى بيوتهم وانا واثق من
هذا وانا شاكر لتركيا التي تدعمنا في هذه
الاعمال
انا ايضا شاكر للسيد الرئيس
خاصه على استبدال الاسرى
وفي الوقت الحالي
سمعنا الطرف الاوكراني السيد الرئيس ونحن
في روس نحن مع روسيا في اخر مراحل من
المفاوضات ومع السيد بوتين تحدثت مع السيد
بوتين عن هذه المساله وفي الشهر القادم
سوف يكون هناك زياره لبوتين الى تركيا
وسوف نتحدث عن هذا من جديد وسوف نتحدث معه
في غرف مغلقه وتحدثنا كثيرا بالهاتف عندما
كان لدينا فرصه
ولذلك
التبادل تبادل الاسرى هو شيء من اولويات
اعمالنا اليوميه
وحتى قبل هذا هذه الامسيه تحدثت عن هذه
المسائل مع السيد الرئيس واننا سوف نعمل
مزيدا وفي اقرب وقت سوف نحصل على نتائج في
هذا المجال
سؤالي للرئين في السابق في العام السابق
بالنسبه
للامم المتحده تم تحضير اتفاق عن
[موسيقى]
اتفاق الحبوب وسوف ينتهي هذا الاتفاق
قريبا فهل هناك اي خريطه اعمال بهذا الشان
حتى يستمر هذا الاتفاق
[موسيقى]
وفي شهر ابريل ابن العام الماضي كان هناك
اتفاقات عن لقاءات مشتركه
[موسيقى]
اعتقد اننا سوف نستمر في اعمالنا على فتح
الممرات لنقل الحبوب والغذاء ومنذ العام
الماضي نعمل على هذا وسوف نرى الى اي حد
سوف نستمر بهذا الاتفاق ونحن نعمل على هذا
نتمنى ان هذا سوف يتم تمديده ليس لشهرين
بل الى ثلاثه اشهر وان نجدد الاتفاق قلت
ثلاثه اشهر وسوف نقوم بكل الجهود اللازمه
للوصول لهذا حتى نقوم باطاله فتره ومدى
هذا الاتفاق الى سنتين
وهذا ما تحدثنا عنه اليوم مع السيد الرئيس
واتمنى من الله تعالى انني سوف اتفق مع
السيد
بوتين الذي تحدثت معه هاتفيا وسوف اتحدث
معه عينا الى عين
وهذه احد اهم المسائل التي نعمل عليها
يوميا هناك دول فقيره وناميه في افريقيا
تنظر باعينها الينا وتنتظر
في هذا المساء تحدثنا ايضا
عن مسائل
الاثنى عشر سفينه المحاصره في الموانئ
الاوكرانيه
واتمنى اننا سوف نستطيع ان نحرر هذه السفن
وقيل لنا انه هناك جهود سوف تعمل على هذا
وهذه سفن تركيه
هي تابعه لرجال اعمال قلقين
ويتساءلون متى سوف تحرر هذه السفن وهذه
البواخر
عدا عن ذلك هناك ممرات
نقل بضائع لا نزل نعمل عليها ونتمنى ان
نحصل على نتائج لم اسمع السؤال عفوا لانه
لم يكن لدي ترجمه ولكن اذا قمت باعاده
السؤال سوف ارد عليك ولكن اول جزء كان عن
الحبوب كما فهمت عن الحبوب ممكن ان اقول
اننا جميع المهتمين بان تستمر هذه
الاتفاقيه والممرات
لنقل الغذاء ومن المهم ان نبدا بالعمل مع
الشركاء
حتى نقوم بامداد حياه ممرات نقل الغذاء
وهذا يعني انقاذ الارواح في مختلف القارات
بما فيها افريقيا حتى لا تكون هذه الارواح
معتمده على مزاج الرئيس الروسي الذي يصبح
معه
ولدينا ممر واحد الان هو موجود وهو ليس
سهل وهو صعب ومعقد بسبب حصار روسيا للبحر
الاسود
واعتقد انه يجب ان يكون هناك ممرات عده
وعندما نتحدث عن نزعه الحصار عن الموانئ
وتحرير البواخر هذا يعني ان على روسيا ان
تتوقف عن قصفها وتوجيها ضربات لهذه
الموانئ ولهذه السفن حتى نحرر هذه الموانئ
بما فيها
ميكالايف
يجب ان نجتمع لاننا لدينا الكثير من
المشاكل والتحديات ولا نستطيع ان نجتمع في
كل مره حتى نقرر كيف علينا ان نعيش في
الشهرين القادمين والعالم كله يتساءل كيف
سوف يتم الاتفاق لذلك يجب ان نتفق ونقوم
بكل شيء حتى لا يعتمد هذا الممر على رغبه
دوله واحده او شخص واحد
شكرا لكم شكرا للجميع
[موسيقى]
اتمنى لكم ليله سعيده اتمنى هذا للجميع